hello and welcome to to the floor of
Stockholm Smithson here in Stockholm
where the ftth conference 2014 just has
started there are people from all around
the world meeting here talking about
broadband FTTH ft TB and we are trying
to collect some of them here in our
studio you will watch as you can watch
us for free during these breaks we have
you can also watch the paid the paid set
the full sessions if you register at the
ftth conference dot EU where you can see
the whole conference and you can choose
between the different locations
different discussion rooms here at the
event actually this event started
already yesterday with the workshops and
it was like a sneak start of the event
and what I've heard this was a total
success for this event I've heard
numbers mentioning around 1300 people
gathering here discussions discussion
making discussions about the broadband
at the the fiber industry and one of the
topics yesterday was about investments
investing in in networks and Thomas
Langer you were the moderator of that
discussion forum or what we call it was
it something special that happened
yesterday what did you discuss well
thanks for having me and i can i can
tell you yes it was a sneak start but it
was definitely not a snake start so so
investment and funding of new networks
has been a core area for the council and
we've been talking about this now for 42
years and i think there is a there's a
growing sense that something more
substantial needs to be done on a
European scale and then also on a nation
by nation basis and we are currently in
a very i would say interesting situation
where maybe the pendulum is just about
maybe to swing back a little bit in
favor of the incumbents who maybe policy
makers on the EU level think they would
be the ones who could solve many of the
issues we currently have in europe okay
but at least here in the Nordics we can
see lots of other investments coming
from from different parts yeah i also
know that you had I pay only which is
funded by a Swedish large risk capital
company with you were there any
discussions about that yeah this is the
beauty of Europe but it's also a bit of
a problem for you because you have very
diverse trends in almost every different
national market so you have the great
luxury and Sweden to maybe be ahead by
five six seven years and maybe if
compared to the average in in Europe and
you have reached a state here where more
than two parties have recognized that
there is a value in fixed infrastructure
so the race is on for essence and you've
started early so assets are in place
where as in many other places in Europe
those networks are just about to be to
be built oh yeah and that is a bit of a
problem so many parts in Europe are late
cycle you're early cycle and what
happened during the cycle is that we had
some technology developments in in
copper which some people think should be
deployed in order to longer use copper
technologies and that was also a topic
that we discussed yesterday is it really
is it really the best approach to just
look at capex and of course renovating
copper is cheaper than building a
completely new acces- but then if you
take into consideration OPEC savings and
deploying a more future proof much safer
technology
maybe one should redo the calculation
but then we as you can sense we move
from a business consideration to a topic
that is being considered on the
political level higher and this is what
is what is not making the story easier
no yeah last year was a very interesting
year in European telecommunications I
mean the EU Commission didn't give the
money that maybe this industry needed to
have to build out the fiber networks and
to build out to reach the target of
connected Europe yeah that's true i mean
it's a it's sad that the industry did
not get a six billion that were under
discussion but to be quite frank six
billion would have been helpful but it
would have been impossible to solve all
the issues was just six billion so
clearly they had the idea that to to add
on private investments but i think is
also fair to say that maybe we should
question the political approach so i
would ask the question is it really good
enough to communicate targets a target
is just a number on a powerpoint slide
on a piece of paper but the crucial
things out how do we get to this target
so I think there's no also growing
evidence and growing understanding that
we need a plan there are an execution
plan a step-by-step approach so we have
that I think that the European
Commission has tried to establish some
steps so to reduce costs for deployment
we think maybe of the regulatory regime
you can or we can discuss whether the
approach is the right one but by and
large and that maybe it's more
applicable more relevant for each
national market we have targets but we
do not really have a plan in many
instances France they seem to have a
plan Germany and from Germany you have
to tell you yes we we have a target but
so far I can't really see a plan that's
the case and some other markets as well
some markets don't need a plan anymore
because you are fairly advanced that
applies to Sweden maybe the Netherlands
in us to a certain degree Switzerland
and Norway but the idea to have a
national plan to do kind of a top-down
plumbing a planning to give some
guidance of where we want to be in xes I
think that has been missing oh yeah yeah
you were talking a little bit about
incumbents earlier they have the money
in many cases at least they have lots of
money they also have networks already
set in place are there at least up here
in the Nordics they are eager to invest
in fiber how does it look in the rest of
Europe well I think maybe they do no
longer have lots of cash many operators
have lots of debt as well and that has
that has caused some some problems for
them how much to spend on new networks
so they need to pay dividends to the
shareholders at the same time they have
number of ventures in other countries
sometimes not even in Europe so how how
to balance this is a real stretch now
coming back to your question what's
going on here in the Nordics yes we have
we have a very lively Swedish market
yeah we have developments now in Norway
Denmark is quite active but quite
interestingly more driven by the by
utilities and Finland is maybe not
moving so fast so even in the Nordics
you have a diverse yeah set of trends
but it's also fair to say that these
trends to invest more in fiber is driven
by a threat by competitors so be it
cable or beard smaller networks on the
muni side then of course if you have a
big PE house like eqt stepping in and
trying to buy our Bassett's what should
the incumbent do they should react and
this kind of a threat scenario is i
think present in markets where you have
strong cable
competition you can really sense this
whether it's no cable you have
essentially no development and I think
the prime example here is Italy yeah
okay so which one are the worst cases in
Europe which one has the longest way to
go to reach the European main target yes
unfortunately have to say Germany is way
behind you you could say well they have
a good copper networking I think that's
true usually they did they deployed good
quality copper this is why you know you
get good speeds with vectoring whether
those speeds will be good enough or will
this is wise investment that again i
would i would have some some some
questions in the UK it's also a
difficult situation probably the copper
there is not as good as in Germany but
has some qualities and BTW has had some
success in getting new subscribers for
the new FF ttc network so i would say
these two markets are tricky italy as i
mentioned you have an incumbent which
faces some balance sheet restrictions
they the former CEO has announced a plan
to look at structural separation now
this plan seems to have been shelved and
the more you think about this and
independently from which point you start
really i think there will be no way
around to consider a structural
separations scenario in those markets
where it could make sense now what does
it mean structural separation here we
talk about a spin-off of the fixed
access operations to run this is a
completely independent company with no
majority ownership of the incumbent and
that's really i mean that's really very
difficult I mean basically we're talking
about that in Sweden we have scan over
which is a runoff but they're still
ruled by telling us near our unmolding
camera so yeah it must be really
difficult it's difficult it's legally
challenging because then you have to
value the assets if there's a spin-off
you have to value the assets
and there might be interest which are
against this and I think one common
story we hear and I think that's a valid
point how do you cope with the over
employment adding comments because that
is the heritage from you know the very
old days now and somehow you have to
solve that issue you have to solve that
issue for for this company and I think
there we also need some support from
from the government but this problem
will not go away because the OTT players
they really don't care about the over
employment cable operators they don't
care about the over employment so you
need to give them a helping hand and to
show them a way out of this misery
otherwise I think it will be quite a
stretch for the incumbents to remain
competitive against the OT T's on the
server side and against the Kaiba cows
on the infrastructure side yeah looking
forward at this event is there something
special you are looking forward to watch
well I have to say yes and maybe if I
could do a little bit of advertising
just as we as we talked about the D the
the incumbents here in the Nordics
tomorrow I will moderate the CEO panel
where we will have to CEO of scan Nova
and the CEO of telenor Norway so they
will give their perspective on how they
see the markets demand drivers and how
to compete against the challengers but
we will also have the CEO of an Israeli
company which will always is the process
of deploying a nationwide FTTH network
together with the largest Israeli
utility and begged by Cisco so this is a
completely different approach and in
their market they are the Challenger so
I think the audience should be prepared
for four different views on what would
be the best approach I can imagine thank
you very much too much for its to do so
much was really pleasure from our side
thank you thank you and as you can see
we are
broadcasting straight from the floor I
don't know whether you can see behind us
people are gathering the eating and
having coffee between the shows and
between the discussions forums and with
us now we have Gilles found then often
very good from the Netherlands I guess
that's right and you were also one of
the moderators yesterday during the
yesterday panels or workshops and being
a Dutch guy coming to Sweden and talking
about the Nordic broadband markets what
are your first impressions of the the
Nordic broadband market coming from
netherlands well it's very exciting the
Nordics are showing how to do broadband
okay and I guess they asked me because
I'm not from the Nordics because the
Nordic countries are all trying to show
off how good they are I and they are
good they are good so everybody has to
have something to learn from from the
Nordics or do the Nordics have anything
to learn from from us or from the other
so sorry well of course I in this world
you all have to learn from each other
yeah the thing about the Nordics is why
they are so fast and it's interesting
because there's a lot of really small
projects in in in the Nordics very small
utilities or City Council's deploying
fiber and when it all adds up it's it's
a big number yeah so were there any main
conclusions from from the discussions
yesterday yes there were um one thing is
on this only small project so one of the
questions was why why can the Nordics be
so successful with all these small
projects and and the Nordics being very
big in size and it's rather difficult to
put fiber in the ground um actually the
answer was well because it's so
difficult and because the distances are
so long fiber actually has the advantage
yeah and before there was no broadband
and the only way to get there was with
fiber so basically the fact that there
was nothing they are at first men's now
they have the advantage because they put
in the fiber oh yeah
do you think this is something something
which is possible to export this this
set up with all these small networks and
getting people if you look at northern
parts of sweden i mean people themselves
are out to digging in the in the ground
when it's not snow and ice of course
well I I have one for you there as well
but but to answer your question of
course the world can learn something
from the Nordics but the situations are
different in every country the geography
is different but I think the model shows
our cooperation is key and so indeed if
you can get your your consumers to do a
large part of the work i mean the cost
of fiber is the installation if you can
get that down then then fiber becomes
very very realistic on the short term
well one of the interesting things with
Sweden is that people actually pay up
front I mean we pay about two thousand
euro up front to get our fiber
connection and we explain that to other
parts of Europe the operators are I mean
they're afraid like this you cannot ask
our customers to pay that much money up
front but it shows who is driving this a
lot of let's say a big operators across
the world are well yeah we don't really
need fiber our broadband is fast enough
and there is really no customer demand
and if a Nordic Swedish Danish Finnish
Norwegian person is is willing to pay
upfront to get his connection I think
that is a proof of the fact that there
is a huge customer demand and people
really need this broadband yeah so you
think it's possible to export this
system a lot of the ideas I don't think
there's a one-on-one export just to to
show you how inventive they are and in
the Norway is a really difficult country
because of all the fjords in the
mountains and the end and the rocks and
and they actually use the ice as an
advantage because normally you would lay
the cables in the summer through the
fjords
we need a ship but now they wait until
winter then there's ice and irate made
the remark yesterday or we Dutch people
only use the ice to win medals at the
Olympics yeah yeah and they actually you
know they open the ice and they walk on
the ice and they just lay the cable oh
yeah and that of course you cannot
export that to a warm country no but you
can use this inventive thinking when we
were talking to I was talking to two on
too much hair earlier it was talking
about a bit a bit about the difference
between the Nordic countries what it was
that something you spoke about yesterday
yeah there was there were regulators
from from Denmark Sweden and Norway but
if you compare that to to the situation
in Finland Finland is quite different
and where's the let's say three
Scandinavian countries are ahead of the
pack finland this let's say on par so
finland needs to to do some catching up
and there's obviously a different
situation there and one of the finnish
operators said hey we we actually have a
little bit of an issue with our city
councils we they don't understand what
we're trying to do and so I think
there's something that needs to happen
in Finland but i'm sure they they can
learn also from from the other examples
yeah finland is definitely a different
market from from the rest of the Nordics
their long history of small networks
owned by local drivers
and also the old incumbent sanara has a
rather small market share when it comes
to their the copper network yes do can
you see that the sauna is investing more
or less or it's a different thing until
and I I think what happens is once the
the small guys start then the big guys
have to come and sometimes in a big
incumbent there are visionaries but very
often they are following and so what
you've seen in in Norway and in Sweden
were there the very small utilities have
have initiated projects and new new
companies have started up to deploy
fiber and then of course the big guys
can't wait in Denmark it's a little
different because in the in Denmark a
lot of utilities have grouped together
to make kind of a consortium and to
compete against the big incumbents who
is quite quite far behind ayuh but now
because they have joined forces these
these utilities actually they are
responsible for a large part of their
success in the Danish market and in the
Finnish market the small guys are having
difficulty to get going yeah so then the
big guys you know waiting and waiting
and sitting on his copper investment
whereas you know we all know where
things are heading yeah I'm because we
all know what the consumer wants in
Sweden we're talking lots about
consolidations we have all of these
small networks and we also have a sweet
spoke with Thomas language earlier we
have EQT risk capital company we have
Talia the incumbents and they're both of
them are trying to buy up small networks
to grow larger is this anything we can
see from our neighbour countries as well
and I I think here you indeed have a lot
of this small
let's say utilities or small networks
and the consolidation is a logical thing
although it's not per se necessary it's
quite traditional thinking to say you
know something must be bigger right i
think with with all this in the digital
age you know small companies have just a
good chance of being successful as the
big guys now and but it is a natural
trend i'm in the in the rest of europe
typically networks tend to be larger
where they are either competing against
the incumbent or the incumbent has
actually decided to do something so
there the consolidation is not that
strong but but there are examples all
over europe where small networks are
being bought up i think thats also shows
the success yeah looking forward we've
just begun there are lots of seminars
today and tomorrow is there anything
special you want to point out which
people who would be watching I I think
and it was also said yesterday in the
workshop on the Nordics and the role of
the consumer is becoming more and more
important but we will think 15 years ago
we were sitting in front no behind the
television and just consuming what was
coming to us yeah but now the consumers
in the driver's seat and he is making
the decisions at saying what what he
wants to watch what he wants to
experience and this was pointed out by a
number of speakers yesterday in in the
workshop and I think this will become a
theme in the conference huh interesting
interesting tell us thank you very very
much for coming here thank you for
having me it was except my pleasure
thank you and that was all from this
broadcast will be back from the floor
here at cocos my son and FTTH conference
at one o'clock with the more interesting
p